foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Amanda
[Applause]
[Music]
what is this costume you're rocking
tonight what is this look ASAP if we
won't explain it to me please give us
some insight to this look at the piece
called Lagerfeld you know this is just
tradition to him and I just wanted to
pay homage the right way a little bit of
kittens you know
that's from my lady
how's the little man doing and growing
big beautiful happy baby thank you for
asking and congratulations on baby
[Music]
do not mess around mama
congratulations sis
[Music]
we're so happy Mom and Dad finally made
it we've been waiting for y'all Mr
mayors
[Applause]
right here
so good
[Music]
[Applause]
yes
oh
you got you getting this video
[Applause]
what a beauty
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
work those ankles
ASAP okay the moment we've all been
waiting for Mom and Dad made it to the
Met ASAP is over here taking in his
beautiful lovely partner Rhianna both
kids now making their debut on the Met
Gala Red Carpet unofficially Of course
asap's wearing Gucci who are you wearing
tonight
oh get it
[Music]
you and ASAP have not been messing
around or maybe you have I don't know
congratulations you got here right
the second pregnancy I think different
from the first one
um just everything all of my
no Cravings tons of nausea
everything's different but I'm enjoying
it I'm enjoying it I feel good I feel
energetic
thank you so much and it looks like that
little guy of yours is pretty energetic
and so happy what Mazda's is are you I'm
in love I'm obsessed and I don't even
feel guilty about it
life is very busy right now you've got
obviously your beautiful growing family
you've got the new Smurf movie but honey
when we're gonna work our nine into the
mixes
you back at it I am you're not gonna
leave me you know what when I do when
I'm ready yeah I coming straight to you
first you better I I have that is a
promise
[Music]
thank you